Female ejaculation!
One of the great mysteries of life is about
to get science’d!
Hi there, I’m Julia here for DNews.
The very existence of female ejacultion was
up for debate for a really long time, even
though descriptions of it date back for thousands
of years.
Ancient Taoist text from the 4th century,
describes the stages of arousal in a woman,
the last saying that when a woman is satisfied
“the gentitals transmit fluid”.
Aristotle even wrote about too, and a recent
study backed up these ancient texts.
While it can be embarrassing for some women,
it’s perfectly natural.
Most women who ejaculate do so through G spot
orgasm, some release a little bit of fluid
through the urethra that’s kind of milky
white in appearance.
Others report expelling a lot of fluid, so
much so that it’s equivalent to the amount
released when urinating.
The study from the Journal of Sexual Medicine
sheds some light on the phenomenon known as
“squirting” or in some cases “gushing”.
While previous studies suggest that the fluid
released is similar to urine, they failed
to find where it comes from.
In this recent study, each of the 7 participants
gave a urine sample and three separate
ultrasounds were performed.
The first confirmed their bladders were empty.
The second, performed when they were close
to climax after stimulating themselves through
masturbation or with a partner, showed significant
refilling of the bladder.
After climax and ejaculation the ultrasound
showed the bladder was indeed empty, identifying
it as the source of the fluid.
To figure what was in the fluid, chemical
analysis showed two things: Two women showed
no difference between their urine and their
“squirted” fluid, but the other five showed
the presence of prostatic-specific antigen.
PSA, as the name suggests is an enzyme secreted
by the prostate gland.
The enzyme liquefies semen which allows sperm
to swim freely.
As this and other studies show, women can
secrete it too, except from the skene gland
which is similar to the male prostate.This
gland varies in shape and size from woman
to woman.
It’s actually so similar some researchers
are moving away from the term Skene gland
and calling it simply the female prostate.
One researcher, Florian Wimpissinger says
that all women have the ability to ejaculate
and most actually do.
It’s just that sometimes the PSA type fluid
flows back into the bladder after orgasm and
isn’t released through the urethra.
The reason for the difference between women
ejaculating and not might be due to the natural
variation in the female prostate.
However while it is in most cases, mostly
urine, it’s nothing to be grossed out by.
It’s more dilute than usual urine, since
the bladder refills quickly during sex, there’s
less waste, so it reportedly doesn’t taste
or smell bad.
So ladies, don’t be embarrassed!
It’s perfectly natural and more common than
you think.
So does that explain away the mystery?
Any other weird questions you have about the
human body?
Let us know in the comments below and don’t
forget to subscribe for more DNews.